you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I'm going to play a 15-5 game
against layer of let's start with the
Knight f6
okay
so what do we do
let's try I think I've had some videos
and standard with the nimzo-indian let's
try let's try maybe a Kings Indian
yeah and might want to transpose into a
benoni in fact
let's see
if the standard moves in let's see f6
okay so Zima SHhhh
in reply to this
slow down I mean like the last standard
video I'm in this speed chest mode
slow down
also too soon for this ready-made attack
I think I want to do something on the
queenside
so what is this exactly
I'm thinking about c6 a6 and b5
way at this pond
doing all this before moving my night
let's start with let's start with a six
of these two this is the more flexible I
still retain the option to play let's
say C 5 and then maybe B 5
I like reserving the C pawn
retaining the sea pawns options
so let's go with let's go with c6 here
the idea was keeping my night here so if
they try to prevent b5 with a 4
I could key in on b4 with a five-night a
six-night B form
at some point
so kind of
holding up waiting to see how white
reacts to this b5 move
and only then will I declare my Knights
intentions
see five I think is the critical move
it's kind of
my weak point now on v6 let's see
I think on c5 I could still play b5 if I
want
so I'm happy to see that they're at
least thinking a little bit
so maybe haven't maybe
haven't seen
this idea before who knows
okay so they're not doing anything might
as well just follow through with this b5
move
so it's not the typical way to challenge
this pawn trio
most common is C 5 and E 5 but I'm going
forward with
cracking at the sieve Han with the beep
on
and so now
Aparna mb5 what can we say
any point I can lure the bishop on c4
and maybe then strike further at what
would then be a pawn duo
chop-chop d5
and if if I could induce eat xd5
and this really can't be good for light
this this f3 pond kind of
now its intention is to support upon an
e4 so if there's no longer upon on e4
it's kind of you know what's its purpose
it has a purpose in securing the bishop
to hang on to the e4 upon
I can also consider a timely kick of the
night although I'm more inclined to
Challenge the pawn Center
now
I was saying
I don't want to counsel too soon
because of this idea
I didn't mention that this idea along
with queenside castle is what would
really scare me
but now that I could be assured that the
queenside would open up some
feel a little bit more comfortable
castling kingside though at the moment I
still don't think that it's necessary
I can form a quark grip in the center
just leave these guys
sitting like this
controlling all four
dance that mower
do I
do that now
what are my candidate moves here Aoife
hassles do I know where my nights gonna
go I only has one square
in fact if he only has one square maybe
I should just put that on right now
yeah I'm gonna do that right now
and in fact now there's I have no fear
of let's say e5
why could have actually considered e5 on
the last move though yeah as I was
saying I think this guy wants to stay
here
I could have a captured and then maybe
played here just played here straight
away if I play d5 instead of this
okay so a three secures the night and
also weakens b3
interesting
now here's another note about my last
move I'm prepared to play Knight to b6
so if I take let's look at the most
forcing stuff first
suppose I take on c4 bishop has to
recapture
I could play this move
Pond takes
I do have a knight v6
which we then bring both my queen and
knight there to reinforce this point I
might have something here
annoying for y because chop-chop d5
and then if this I'm good with Knight b6
I've successfully broken up the center
chop-chop d5 and let's say the bishop
returns to d3 or a2 probably a2
well not now b3 I should say because
he's in trouble there
chopped d5 let's say Bishop d3 I get
chopped again
recapture the peace
I'm happy and if white captures with a
pond that gives me Lake g4
how does it how's that position looking
it's tough for me to envision what that
looks like
roni chaperone ed5
Bishop back so basically same position
are off the board he's on this square
and I have d5 in and it's my move
by chop they still have a pond ooh oh
yeah I'm liking that actually
might see six up see six panel do a good
job to controlling the knight on c3 and
I could I could even follow up with pawn
to e5
night is either way I have an EVE 95
move Bishop goes here I have this Bishop
goes here I have maybe this kind of
stuff I'm gonna I'm gonna say let's go
for this
caPSURE you know it makes sense also
because leave it uh
and a target one of the weak squares on
v3
so let's follow up with this idea to
break up their pawn center that's now
down to
do Oh
so what to do
let's see
first time playing this opponent slayer
of
you
you know take here or here
I really don't know which of the I'm
pretty sure that Bishop moved to one of
these two is best
this one certainly has its points
because I will be castling kingside and
to keep a piece opposite or my King will
eventually be can't be too bad and it
would watch over a hole from b3
so that's nice
I don't know if I'd be too quick to put
work on the B file because after b4
no no no it could hear hear
I'm not really thinking so much about my
rec room though more more concerned
about counseling and we'll really
breaking up this Center how is the
structure going to change in the center
so we could be left with each of us
could be left with isolated ponds so
here chop if they take with the piece
our pawns are a knight's move apart and
both isolated
suggested envisioning these two
disappearing
we would have and again this guy is kind
of
feels a little bit weird
I have to follow through with this idea
so it's an uncomfortable moment
for why to take with a piece or a pun
now I have to be care of
okay so should I go straight in for this
Knight to g4
like this is the the principled move
I'm gonna say let's do it I move my
night forward I throw a punch I opened
my bishops eyes
and I could think about a five
you know in my earlier calculation I was
thinking Bishop f2 is a mouth no it's
not
so where does the bishop go you
certainly can't allow me to take out the
knife for Bishop
could try
play that position the computer will be
maybe somewhere around even but this is
the more valuable Bishop I would say
with white having pawns on f3 and e4 you
know he's more so the the bad Bishop
though the structure isn't fixed he's
the more valuable of the two
secures the King once Castle kingside
now he must leave
going back to g1 and then this
just to Fonz's the shelter for the white
king with still all this traffic on
board
is a bit scary so let's consider the
forward-most this will be pretty much
shot down with e5
so on this month
have h6 which is a desirable move in
nearly all cases when your fee and cut
out to have that new square available
for the king
he goes here or back home let's say here
what would I do I think I'm just playing
E 5
you know II five and then even if h32
shoe my night away I could maybe even
ignore it
capturing on efj on d4 and then I'd be
on the night
I'm going to say let's do it
also
a ch3 maybe Queen h4 though there is g3
I could back up though
unprotected on each one
so there's a couple diagonals towards
the white King Queen h4 possibly Queen
to b6 this is a very nice shelter for my
king
do you five
okay let's go
that's giving up
striking at the unprotected bishop
also the
diagonal is now officially opened so
this is pretty serious most serious move
maybe six friends me queen bee six I
think wins the game
defend Queen f2
here it
upon hit the rook and then even return
hitting the rook yet again
so here there's no
should move that's going to defend here
no night move no night move no Queen
move
six rook f1 Knight takes pawn
this is already busted for white I even
have
hmm
I even have the night jumping into e3
or taking a b2 though that that's I'm
going after the king
and I'm looking more soaked going after
the King than picking up a beep on and
allowing some counterplay
now the only concern I have is that if I
don't keep up with these threats in the
end there is a pawn takes pawn and
they're on my knight and there's a new
square for this night
so Queen b6 rook f1 Knight takes pawn
maybe the rook doesn't have to move
you
let's consider a check here g3
and of that
hmm
how about Queen b6 and then after rook
f1
now Queen b6 Rock f1
let's see Queen p6 rook f1
Knight takes h2 King side is just
shredded
one takes pawn
maybe in that position
I moved my knight out of harm's way and
defend against ninety-five
still a little bit scary that phone is
becoming past is there something better
here I mean I don't want to take because
I'm inviting the night forward and I
don't have Queen to b6 anymore
I don't want to
this
I want to start with Queen b6 I haven't
calculated it all for sure
okay fun is they should probably rattle
that one out fast
like I could pause for a moment here and
just play Bishop to b7
you
a little bit careful f7
so here here here clean here then I
could just castle them I'm cool with
that
takes h2 pawn takes pawn Oh like I could
just recapture with my queen
in around the rook still
I could simply recapture on c6 with my
queen I guess earlier I was hesitant to
pull the Queen off of this diagonal so
anything better here here chop chop chop
my Queens pretty invasive but they're up
on Andy's past I don't want to allow any
fancy counter play I want to keep this
simple I think takes fun
pawn takes pawn choline takes pawn
95 I could just take the rook
he takes pawn pawn takes pawn queen
each one
night back to g4
I have to be very careful I have to be
very very careful here here here here
rook here Knight back to G 495 is
threatening rook c1 hitting my queen and
then Knight to c7 with the fork and I
cannot castle because there's Knight to
e7 with the fork against my queen and
king king and queen
huh
should I just start with
ship to be seven
hmm
they here
maybe not here first
think I like Bishop to b7 and maybe go
after there
wasting so much time
spending on China put the Seas Bishop d7
each three night here chop shop clean
here
hitting my bishop I have night c5
I'm going to say Bishop b7 and I'm
prepared to just take out their dark
square bishop this really concerns me I
know they're uncancelled but and this
night not surprising link could be a
great father
five preventing castling and has
mentioned combined
on the coordination on c7
exhausted a lot of time there
so are you gonna shoe my night away he
is just hanging so any night move will
throw a punch though I don't see any
great moves for the night here on g3 I'm
just jumping in
let's see I just want I want to get
castled get my king get my king safe
that's it this is a developing move
there are some punches that's around it
my queen though I'm fine with that I
back up I stay on this nice diagonal
coordinate with my knight you know let's
just jump right in
that's a fork okay so we have
a super invasive queen now if I could
just complete development get castled
I'm one move away I'm happy
and I think I'll be able to do that
I have a master Bishop now
mr. Bishop Master bishop
a nice ring to it
so what's white gonna do this pawn
controls this Knight this pond slash
Bishop controls this Knight
okay where to go
I wanna say here
stop Queen b3 and I'm not inconvenienced
with Knight to h4 our Knight to a4 I
have my knight here that controls him
I would love to see him go to a four
because I now have to worry about this
you know after I back up then I'd be
threatened to win upon this doesn't
concern me
this feels like a liability more so than
an asset
and I would have a blockade er
big question is what will whites minor
pieces do
maybe some pressure here
okay have that
I should probably just
households no no time to be greedy
time to go after Ponce over castling now
they're ready to take and then
sensitive so I'm tucked in
they could try to eliminate the light
scrap bishops and then go here be
careful of entering a bad he's my he's
my master bishop right I do have to be
careful though about light-square bishop
exchange knight jumping in here trying
to work around that guy okay so actually
they could why can still Castle
queenside
yeah let's not forget about that
you do how about this and then I'm
prepared to take care I want to move my
night it's time to improve him a
second-rank night no good he could do
better here and then still fight for the
d5 square
I think that's the way forward
Knight f6
yeah Knight f6 it is and also I'm
prepared to put some more pressure on
the D line
do I want to do this with which rook
Queen rook
this is sensitive and then I'll probably
need some support of f7
interesting game
they are able to complete development
Council
I would love to see this epon recapture
on d5 because then
are brought to life on b2 I start to
coordinate
so I'm expecting queenside castling on
that shop
see how white recaptures
I'm gonna say
do I take first and then go here or go
here first you know I want to I want to
make sure the C file opens up so shop
probably this
I just put a little bit more no I don't
want to see this at this point let's
take
let's take
I mean we'll see I'm saying I don't want
to move this route maybe it maybe I do
things are sharpening so see file is
appealing
keep in mind the the checks
bishop here is now working
ix they are on the Queen I got to take
that guy how do I want to take it the
bishop for the night
hmm
you
I say the bishop actually
context I have this so my rook is under
fire now
you
where does he want to go now I have a
check I have multiple checks Queen rook
hmm you know I could take here
and if Queen here
this then there's that
if I do this first night here kind of
guards everything
hmm
this I'm just flushing the King away to
ask where he wants to go to
you
tough check there's even rough block a
minute 30
a tough car
you
hmm yeah I'm going to take
and maybe I put pressure on b2 instead
of attacking the Queen
here threatens me
you
let's see let's see how white reacts to
that first
let's say they're doing a good
defending
after that breaking up for the central
structure and then getting the dark
square bishop
so how to defend this point
oh boy that's so weakening
oh man there there has to be something
hmm
I could do this if Queen takes I have a
check and then I get to you for let's
try gotta go with something fast
keep him defended
Queen takes follows I don't have that
okay let's still throw on the check
there's a night block
not calculated
you
but this cuts off this communication
here
9c3 has to be played Queen here and then
he'll be able to move and I open up the
this diagonal
it has to go into a pin
Knight c3 rook here Queen to one of
these two and if I take
yeah
III walk with the rook think that's a
losing move I take here and I'm on the
night they just blundered
nothing my Queens not getting trapped
just blundered there
sudden end
open position Knight c3 and maybe I have
some of that k let's let's focus here
let's let's get the move back with check
the rook cannot block
and this bishops eyes need to open up
right now he could finally see
pushing
forward
just keep him defended this
sensitive square
let's keep pushing
try and score touchdown
so no tactics have to be sometimes
careful if there was rip takes and then
Queen takes rook
okay I'm gonna go here with the check
yeah is then I want to be able to push
next and push
and I even am coordinating now with my
bishop
you know pushing through and there's
some added support to my most sensitive
square f7
you're going to have to give up a rook
for this pawn
I'm not sure what I would do if 9c3 was
played instead of rooks III they just
missed this idea and
and that other one okay
well I could win the Queen not quite
just push the pawn
yeah
just keep more than ten seconds in lvr a
you
might be resigning right about here
okay and Gigi slayer of
let's see
and go back
so I think this is after c6 the most
critical move try and take advantage of
b6
let me let me jump into the analysis
somebody already clicked on the computer
evaluation
yeah so
rather son
c-5a move here
here c5 ism of
structure that was played in the game I
got b5n he five is a possibility could
shake a change in many ways
right out it's a fan of castles Bishop
to b7 you know this is where I went for
breaking up their pawn trio Bishop b7 is
another move better move apparently
this is okay too
and is this okay
yeah I guess this is alright as well
where does it really change oh it wants
to go 405 right now okay
ie 5 is another move but the so too is
the move Clayton in the game yeah so
this is an important moment I guess
mm-hmm mine has to recapture with the
piece here taking with a pond and I'm
getting some initiative now kicking off
with Knight g4
yeah he 5d 5 likes Queen b6 gotta go to
f1 no I just want to take on h2 hmm
I played the second-rate move so let's
consider this a knight takes h2 what
concerned me was this
a pawn takes pawn I don't have to do
this I could counterpunch here here I
missed this in my calculations this and
I felt that I was in trouble
and I would be 95
this close by you know it's that's
that's too scary and I can't get my king
safe because of that okay I missed that
I have night to see five and reply to
this capture in my calculation
so I could have gotten away with
capturing on h2 there okay so I missed
my chance there
three as our rights
once called a bit all the way back to a
seven
hmm 94 I was saying
right with them
huh
what's the idea night a for Queen a
seven and then just once to bypass
okay then consider that
castles
to
and just at this point I wanted a fight
for the d5 square
so right
queenside castle takes and - - so what
did I miss here
hmm it was - - and then it's jumping
around a little bit okay
just have to give it some time to think
maybe it's not - - after all - one can
fish if takes it's all right with night
takes it's all right with right around
here I must have missed something
I like Sergei to be atha
v5 yeah and I guess I could have
improved here I went with a five and
that throws the advantage away and I'm
still I still have something I must
always have something here Queen still
owned all major pieces still on in the
king without a pawn shelter
so Queen takes a five queen c6 and after
Knight c3 white is better so that's how
close this is
it'll still be tough to hold I imagine
for whitey easy to go wrong I mean as it
has it happened in the game but yeah I
had to follow up in a different way okay
now that there isn't as much pressure on
f7 this rook I guess I could feel a bit
more confident bringing this rook and
into play and if Knight c3 here exchange
Queens oh I don't know if I would have
wanted to do that okay maybe if I saw
that I was
I'm going to be able to win both of the
a ponds
hmm
I don't know tricky
certainly a very tricky
I mean c6 and now it's just gone even
yeah I mean I'm getting the night but
it's already minus 4
how could I followed up queen f4
yeah here's the thing as soon as his
eyes are up enough there's no there's
nothing good he's also past so even if
he falls at some point I'm diverting one
of their pieces away and so I could
probably do something in the queenside
then
hmm
gone from here of course what is the
once the graph reading inaccuracies
mistakes blunders for each let me just
go back to the opening real quick what
kind of white have Dunson what could
white have done that's a little bit
better because I was successful with
breaking up this tree on I don't know if
I should have been so successful so
maybe instead of a three and a fan of a
three so clean d2 and if white sphere
was b4 to chase the night away
there's night a four
- maybe I have to be concerned about c5
at some stage it's following up with a
five and then now now there's an 83 move
to try and hammer away at the one pawn
that's in White's house so doing without
a three Queen to d2 what might have what
might I have done
probably Castle has mentioned now that I
could be assured that this side the
board will be opened up if they go Queen
side I'm not too scared about this idea
and let's say white castles
I could follow up with E 5 it's still a
very interesting struggle it's tough to
say how exactly the the central
structure will be defined many different
ways it could it could change up
but I guess to do without a three is one
a quick note for for the white side just
Queen to d2 castle and
yeah
the a3 don't be maybe afraid of the
night getting shooed away to a four
that's a minor point but uh anyhow feel
free as usual to leave any feedback to
this rapid game in the comment section
below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you